A SPACE SUIT
IS A PRESSURIZED GARMENT
THAT ASTRONAUTS WILL WEAR
THAT IS MEANT TO RE-CREATE
THE CONDITIONS ON EARTH.
WHEN YOU GO OUT
TO THE VACUUM OF SPACE,
THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THAT'S KEEPING YOU ALIVE.
Narrator: SPACEWALKS CAN BE
AS LONG AS 8 HOURS.
AND AN ASTRONAUT CANNOT
SIMPLY GO BACK
INSIDE TO USE THE BATHROOM.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS SOLVED BY
THE MAXIMUM ABSORBENCY GARMENT.
VERY FANCY WORD
FOR AN ADULT DIAPER.
EVERYBODY WORE DIAPERS
AT SOME POINT.
SO I GUESS IF
YOU'RE AN ASTRONAUT,
YOU'RE JUST GOIN' BACK
TO YOUR ROOTS.
Hernandez: WHEN YOU GET INTO
THE SPACE SUIT,
THE FIRST THING YOU DO
IS YOU PUT ON YOUR DIAPER.
AND THEN YOU PUT ON
YOUR COOLING GARMENT.
WITHOUT THE COOLING
UNDERGARMENT,
THE ASTRONAUT CERTAINLY
COULD OVERHEAT
BECAUSE INSIDE
THE SPACE SUIT,
THERE'S NOWHERE FOR
THE BODY HEAT TO ESCAPE.
Woman: SPACE SUITS HAVE BEEN
AROUND A REALLY LONG TIME.
AND THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
SEVERAL GENERATIONS
WHERE THEY GET
BETTER AND BETTER.
Waldman: THE FIRST ASTRONAUT
SUITS ON THE MOON
WERE ACTUALLY MORE
FLEXIBLE LATEX SUITS.
TODAY, HUMANS CAN
MOVE AROUND A LOT
MORE THAN THEY COULD
IN PREVIOUS SPACE SUITS.
Narrator: WITH ONLY TWO EMUs ON
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION,
THE SPACE SUITS
HAVE TO BE SHARED.
SO THEY HAVE DIFFERENT SIZES:
MEDIUM, LARGE, EXTRA LARGE.
THEY CAN BE RECONFIGURED.
AND IT'S DESIGNED TO BE ABLE
TO ACCOMMODATE 95%
OF THE ASTRONAUTS.
Narrator: THE MAIN SUIT
IS COMPRISED OF THE HUT,
WHICH STANDS
FOR "HARD UPPER TORSO,"
AND THE LOWER TORSO.
IN TOTAL, THERE'S ABOUT
11 LAYERS TO THE SPACE SUIT:
SHELL, A BLADDER LAYER
TO REGULATE PRESSURE,
FIVE LAYERS OF MYLAR
TO REGULATE TEMPERATURE,
A WATERPROOF LAYER,
A FIREPROOF LAYER,
A BULLETPROOF LAYER IN CASE
ANY SPACE GANGSTERS FLOAT BY.
THAT'S A JOKE.
ONE OF THE LAYERS
IN THE SPACE SUIT
MAKES YOU SPACE DUST-PROOF.
SPACE DUST IS CREATED
FROM ASTEROIDS.
IT COMES AT YOU ABOUT THE SPEED
OF A SPEEDING BULLET.
IF IT'S GOING SUPER-FAST,
NO MATTER HOW SMALL IT IS,
IT'S GONNA HURT YOU.
AND THOSE 11 LAYERS
REALLY PROTECT YOU.
THE COMMUNICATIONS
CARRIER ASSEMBLY
IS WHAT YOU PUT ON YOUR HEAD.
IT HAS EARPHONES
AND A MICROPHONE
FOR YOU TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THE STATION IN THE GROUND.
Narrator: THE CLOTH CAP FASTENS
UNDER THE CHIN
AND KEEPS THE HEADSET IN PLACE
ON THE ASTRONAUT'S HEAD.
WE CALL THE CCA,
THE COMMUNICATIONS
CARRIER ASSEMBLY,
THE SNOOPY CAP.
WHEN SNOOPY USED TO FIGHT
WITH THE RED BARON,
HE USED TO HAVE THAT
WORLD WAR I FLIGHT CAP.
AND THAT'S WHY WE CALL IT
THE SNOOPY CAP.
THE HELMET IS ESSENTIALLY
A CLEAR PLASTIC BUBBLE
THAT ALLOWS THE
ASTRONAUT TO BREATHE.
Man: THERE'S A GOLD VISOR
THAT COMES DOWN IN CASE
YOU'RE IN THE DIRECT SUNLIGHT.
IF IT'S VERY, VERY BRIGHT
AND YOU'RE HAVING TO WORK,
YOU HAVE ANOTHER METAL VISOR
THAT COMES DOWN LIKE
THE VISOR ON YOUR CAR.
THIS VISOR ASSEMBLY
HAS A CAMERA SYSTEM.
WE ALSO HAVE A COUPLE OF LAMPS
TO WORK IN THE DARK.
AND YOU HAVE A STRAW
RIGHT HERE AT YOUR MOUTH.
YOU CAN JUST DRINK
ALL THE WATER YOU WANT.
[ SLURPING ]